this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you for the very nice introduction
this so quick seminar overview first
going to talk about disease resistance
bleeding in the Cornell great breeding
program then I'm going to talk about
three topics that are made up my
dissertation the first is using computer
vision to detect or quantify downy
mildew and leaf trichomes the next part
will be to integrate genetic information
snips in this case with multiple
phenotypes in something called the
Bayesian network and finally I'll talk
about accounting for spatial effects in
field data with grapevines so just an
overview of grapes they're perennial
there are two main groups that we work
with Vitis vinifera which is the
European grapevine it's susceptible to
virtually a breed disease but it has
very good wine quality as well as
certain table grape attributes that we
want and the other group is various by
the species that are native to North
America and so these species are
resistant to nearly every disease
however they have really poor wine
quality however sometimes we do want
there our table great characteristics
and so the goal of the program is to
merge the best of both worlds
to obtain hybrids that have a high
disease resistance as well as high wine
quality or table so how great breeding
works in the corner corner process
returned' then if markers we have
certain markers retreats
as disease resistance then those
seedlings plant the vineyard
after years of multi-location multi-year
trials of evaluating for field disease
resistance as well as wine quality the
best of those selections are releases
cultivars so the first bird I'll be
talking about you about is computer
vision so what is computer vision it's
using algorithms to extract information
that's from images that's usually
attracted using human vision and so the
pros is that there this method is
high-throughput I get a lot of data fast
that you could obtain quantitative
phenotypes and that there's a lot of
high-level programming libraries they're
available in order to implement these
algorithms for example the one I used
it's called open CV or open computer
vision some negatives with this method
it's time consuming to develop and it
requires technical knowledge from end
users which the phyto pathologists or
breeders indices so all about downy
mildew this is how it looks like so on
the left-hand side is the back seal side
of the leaf and this is where the oh my
seed infects this stomata and you obtain
sporulation
and essentially for Vitis vinifera you
need to spray about every two weeks if
it's a really rainy year and so it's
calm you thought that this kind of
intensive pesticide application is no
longer sustainable so now I'll talk
about the genetic resources that I've
used to evaluate this method the first
is or both of them are interspecific f1
hybrids the first is bias group estrus
by horizon so virus repressors is a
native Native American virus species and
horizon is an inter specific cross it
has Vitis vinifera in its background as
well as other virus Easy's and so for
both of these we have genetic Maps
available so there's about 6,000 snips
and the population size is 160 so I'll
call this family RH and other family is
horizon bye-bye the scenario the invited
scenarios of wild Vitus species and
what's special about this family is that
it has a back seal leaf trichomes so
there's two images of leaf disks per
family
the left-hand one is prior to
inoculation and on the right-hand side
believe this what it looks like the same
leaf this after inoculation so you could
see both of them the sporulation on both
but it's much harder to see on leaf this
when it has leaf trichomes and that's
because they believe trichomes are white
and sporulation zweite so it's difficult
to differentiate them and so the idea
that I'll use is using
the computer vision rating prior to not
religion as a co-vary to control or
belief trichomes and so the particular
last essay that we use as a leaf this
assay so basically we took leaf this or
took leaves from the field made leaf
this and plated them on an auger dish
and the leave this correspond to
genotypes shown in the grid here the
experimental design here's for the RH
family we have controls and we did this
over two years 2015 and 2016 in 2015 we
had three experiments in 2016 we had two
for each experiment there was a time
series collection of data from three DPI
or days post inoculation to six DPI or
sometimes it was four dpi to seven dpi
if we didn't see sporulation after the
DPI so we collected four leaves from
each genotype and each leaf from each
leaf extract the two leaf this so for
each experiment we had about 1,400 and
so the only difference between our H
family and the HC family experimental
design is that in 2015 we only had two
experiments for the HC family and ours
just due to lack of time so we compared
the computer vision rating with a manual
rating so this is the scale it's a one
to five scale where one is no
sporulation and five is dense
formulation so
oh how we did the computer vision or
what algorithm did is that you have this
input image and what we want to do is
remove the background biography from it
as well as detect the leaf disks and so
this requires some user input of
parameters and so the next thing that we
want to do is if you notice on the
second row of belief this there's
greater illumination than in the first
row and we wanted we had to correct for
that and the somebody call it Wallis
filter check won't go into but
essentially corrects versus normalizes
the illumination across an image and
then we could detect the or phenotype
which in this case is the amount of
white pixels in belief this divided by
the area of a belief disk so now go into
the results first I'll just explain or
one experiment so here's the computer
vision ratings on the left hand side so
this cyan color is three days post
inoculation and so you could see it's
very close to zero
and then four days we get kind of the
distribution moves up as you get further
along in the days post occupation the
distribution keeps moving forward and
it's relatively normally distributed
however compare this to the manual
sporulation ratings you could see that
three DPI it's skewed all the way to the
one rating and
you get further along it skews towards
the five and so the ratings here are the
average the average of eight leave this
for a particular genotype add-on for an
experiment so here are all the other
[Music]
distributions you can see the trend is
similar across experiments where it's
well that we normally distributed and
computer vision ratings
[Music]
looking at the correlations between
methods we see that the correlations are
very high and so this shows that our
method or computer mission method has is
accurate and obtaining a good phenotype
and you can see when we averaged across
genotypes the correlation increases
so now going onto the computer for the
HC family so this family had leaf
trichomes and so the computer vision
ratings were the ratings after
accounting for belief trichome computer
vision ratings which were simply the
computer vision ratings at two days post
inoculation prior to any sporulation on
leafless and so you can see that it's
not as clear in the computer vision
distributions that there's a general
trend of increasing sense for you lesion
however it's not as clearly defined and
for example in the first experiment at
seven a seven days post inoculation
it kind of moves down instead of you
know being close to five and six blue
and purple in the first graph however
for the manual sporulation readings are
again skewed or in the case of the
person just uniformly distributed
looking at the correlations they were
much lower averaging across genotypes
help increase the correlations a little
bit but not by a lot and for one
experiment the every all the days post
inoculation correlations weren't
significantly different than the zero
and the reason for that is we didn't get
a good reading of potentially the
computer vision reading Wilson didn't do
a good job in obtaining belief tricone a
true rating and so kind of the the use
of the co-vary didn't really work in
that
and so one way to improve it would be to
standardize illumination to maybe
improve obtaining that leaf Tricon
rating but to use as a as a covariant
there's a summary looking at the rating
of processing times over 1400 leave this
the manual visual rating took three
hours while the computer vision took 20
minutes so there's a great improvement
in how much she could phenotype and if
you want more information about this
vital pathology paper is out this for
this research and all the code is on my
github link shown below
so some future directions in this
research there's a comment by mornin the
last time I gave this talk about if you
see that da because of this parameter
search kind of need to set parameters
where you detect all the leafless at the
same time which is really easy to do for
the RH family comes with it for the HD
family you still get like the detected
circles that are much smaller in some
cases so this method that's recently
been published
Els DC played around with it and seems
like a good way to remove this pram
research another direction to go into is
to generalize phenotype detection for
example in this in my case I'm detecting
white pixels over what if the disease
was red if we could model the pixels is
coming from particular clusters then it
would could generalize this method
so reviewing are the phenotypes we
obtained for these two families we have
manual and computer vision sporulation
ratings going forward I'll just talk
about the manual sporulation ratings
because of the kind of problems we've
had you in the HC family with these
ratings and we also as I mentioned
collected the leaf tricone ratings at
today's post inoculation and we also
collected hypersensitive response or RH
ratings which were collected today's
post inoculation before any sporulation
and we're essentially the rating scale
is the detection of black dots which
represents necrosis so a rating of five
has dense necrosis so one of the
questions is what few notes actually use
for QTL detection we have eight readings
per genotype per experiment and how we
integrate this is with a mixed model so
our response in this case is the average
of eight ratings are fixed effects are
the intercept the experiments within
years and the leaf trichome ratings if
and belief track on ratings only for the
computer vision ratings for the HC
family
then we have random effect I ran in fact
of the breeding value or the genotypes
which here we assume that all the
genotypes are independent and we include
genotype by year effects again assuming
that the the years are independent and
we fit this using M rebel which is in
our package so the simplest QTL
detection is just using us the single
phenotype so use the term phenotype but
I'm really going to use the breeding
value as my the response in this case so
the basic idea is you scan the genetic
map for significant snips and you
include them in your model and you keep
doing this until no more snips are so
this equation when a particular
phenotype equals an intercept plus snip
one multiplied by the fact of suit 1
plus snip 33 x by the effect of where
the sips are fixed effects and we did
this with our TTL in our package and
what I want to shoot this step is that
the QTL are often not robust when you
have a small population size so in this
case we only have 160 individuals so say
you 10 or 10% you might end up with
different key TL so we kind of want
ideally method that's provides robust
GTR because when we're going to invest a
lot of effort and using them for
marker-assisted selection
so in order to essentially understand
how had phenotypes affect phenotypes our
phenotype is back or how gene or snips
affect multiple phenotypes one thing we
do is adjust that prior method and
simply scan for the most significant
snip or phenotype and so you could end
up with a model that's some phenotype
one is the response and is explained by
you know type two for example so in
order to do this we need to be sure that
we include effects that only kinda makes
sense
make biological or mechanistic sense so
for example if we have leaf trichomes
equal or being affected by correlation
in this case that doesn't make sense
because leaf trichomes were present on
the leaf
prior to inoculation and so the model
will not make sense and so we don't want
consider it and so an effective way to
do that multiple phenotype analysis is
by using something known as basing
networks so what these what you're doing
here is you're adding effects in
something called a greedy manner until
an additional longer increases the
network's basing information criterion
or bi C so I'll explain a few terms in
that sentence the first is what is a
network it's multiple separate linear
models one per phenotype so these will
just only be fixed effect linear models
the bi C is the likelihood of a
particular model subtracted by a
penalization term which is a function of
the population size and the number of
parameters in that model the network's B
I see is simply a sum of individual
models individual model BICS and gree
addition means the addition of an effect
to a particular model that increases the
network's B I see the most and so the
the reason they're called Bayesian
networks is simply because we're using
the basing information so now I'll give
an example of how this is done so assume
we have two phenotypes correlation and
HR or hypertension or hypersensitive
response and two snips and so these
orange arrows represent all possible
effects so immediately will not attempt
to account for the effect of sporulation
on HR because spoil because HR appears
prior to sporulation and we do not allow
phenotypes to affect genotypes
so then we essentially go one by one
with these effects and asks which one
increases the network's B I see the
greatest and this is a hypothetical
example just snip two effects at the
most and we do this again asking every
which estimating every effect and asking
which one increase the IC so it's this
one in this case then it's this one and
then we come up to a point where no more
no addition of any of these arrows
increases the b IC of the model and so
you're left with the two left the two
models which this network represents
which is that sporulation is affected by
HR which is this arrow and snip - and HR
is affected by sleep - only she has
sporulation and HR so this method is to
computationally intensive to do with
thousands of steps so we select a non
redundant set of steps for each
phenotype and it's the name of that set
is called the Markov blanket so we'll
have one Markov blanket for each
phenotype so then we construct 1,000
networks using random sets of 90% of the
genotypes views for both our H and CHC
families then we merge all the networks
in one where we only keep the facts that
appeared in at least 50% of the networks
and we do this with the BN learn package
so the results for the RH family so you
could simply represent any linear model
with in this network
representation so I'll just do that for
the single phenotype ETL analysis
results and so the difference only here
is that the phenotypes will not affect
each other and the single analysis so
what we see in the Bayesian network is
that there is no effect of HR on
sporulation just the only possible
phenotype interaction that I allowed and
that the sniff generally found or are in
the same chromosome so if you are
similar however the main difference is
that in the single phenotype detail
analysis sporulation trade had many more
keep y'all found word and basic Bayesian
network it's a little bit more
interesting in the HC family where we
found that each type owns have a
negative effect this red arrow on
sporulation and HR and HR had a positive
effect on sporulation and so we don't
know why this is the case but for belief
trichome negative effects on the disease
phenotypes
it's hypothesized that it forms a
physical barrier between the spores of
the home IC and the stomata on the back
side of the leaf and that would prevent
spores from germinating and looking at
the single phenotype QTL analysis
it's somewhat uninformative because all
the phenotypes were explained by the
same two QTL in chromosome chromosomes
by Vinnie so the question is you know
what's really going on there and the
Bayesian network kind of explains that
but otherwise the QTL are similar and
could see seven affecting exfoliations
found here and the cutie on chromosome
six affecting EHRs also summarize this
the disease resistance in the two
families is controlled by multiple QTL
and they only account for a small
percent of the phenotypic variants that
breeding four-leaf trichomes as well as
other QTL would could possibly lead to
durable resistance again because you
have that physiological type of
physiological barrier mechanism and say
a mechanism that's biochemical where
there's say necrosis occurring to stop
in action Bayesian networks are one way
to integrate multiple phenotypes with
genetic data as we've seen and one
question is are basing networks better
models Turner's to do this we would need
to perform cross validation so I haven't
done that formally but preliminary D
experiments do suggest that basing
networks are just using single
phenotypes
so now I'll move on to accounting for
spacial effects in vineyards so as I
mentioned we commonly phenotype in the
field as opposed to in the lab as the
previous methods did and it's commonly
done in unreplicated vineyards although
not in all cases
so some assumptions one can make is that
the phenotypes that we measure the best
representation of the meaning values
another assumption is that the
phenotypes are corrupted by a complex
function of soil microclimate and
genetics this is likely the case however
the problem with this is that we really
don't have the data to fit this model
because we don't do not have meter by
meter soil data in our vineyards so one
could use the location of the vines as a
proxy for that and so that's essentially
what we're gonna gonna use a mixed model
here the response would be corrupted
phenotypes or what I'll call corrupted
phenotypes which is simply the
phenotypes that are measured in the
field and that's going to be explained
by some spatial effects and the noise
will be our uncorrupted phenotypes and
so the spatial effects will be
controlled by this L matrix it's
somewhat similar to a genetic
relationship matrix instead of this
matrix being a function of snips it's
going to be a function of the location
of the vines in the field and so there's
a number of ways you can encode this but
I'll just talk about two one is called
moving average covariance model and
others not are aggressive and they're
commonly used in time series analysis
so to explain these models I'll have a
really simplified example where I have
four vines in a row and I'm gonna see
how or what covariance is these various
models give so the simplest one is
called a moving average one model where
you're only modeling the covariance
between adjacent binds and this you
could see the encoding of this of the L
matrix here where this a which is a
value between 0 & 1 is kind of the
covariance between the first and second
vine and and goes down the diagonal so
this can you represent the gear so
moving average to milos a little more
complex where neighboring vines are
explained by a plus a times B young bees
value between 0 & 1 that we're going to
optimize and B and the covariance
between the first and third vine is a
value and here's the corresponding
covariance matrix another regressive one
is simply saying that there's an
exponential decline or an exponential
decay of covariance as you go as you go
further along so neighboring vines have
covariance of a then the next one then
between the first and third is a squared
and between the first and fourth is a
cube and so because it is between 0 & 1
is to go further along even good you're
gonna have coherence is closer to 0
so then you have an autoregressive -
which is a little more complicated
essentially you could the easiest way to
think of it as as combining two
autoregressive one covariances so again
you have this B parameter now however if
you said B equal to zero it's going to
revert back to an AR 1 co variance and
so here this l1 is simply this value and
L 0 is 1 and so the covariances are
really to the previous covariances so to
evaluate how well these models perform
a data set which is again an F 1 in a
specific cross similar to the the
previous crosses explained there's six
rows here and 110 binds with in a row
I'm only going to model the covariances
within a row because the small number of
rows that we have there's four hundred
seventy four hundred seventy five bonds
that have been phenotype for powdery
mildew on a one to five scale in 2002
and 350 of them have genetic data so how
I'm going to do this evaluation is I'm
going to fit that mixed model they're
explained previously
and with the uncorrupted phenotypes I'm
going to do a qtr analysis and I'm also
going to do leave 10% out cross
valuation so what that means I'm going
to use 10% so I'm going to use 90% of
the genotypes that have genetic we're
phenotypes Abnett data as in this model
and so this model is essentially G block
which is again another mixed model we
are similarly how we had that spatial
covariance matrix we now just have
the genetic covariance matrix as
explained by van Raden and then we
predict the test genotypes with the
parameters estimated from that model and
we're going to compute an accuracy score
which is the Pearson correlation between
the predicted and true uncorrupted or a
corrupted
so looking at the results spatially
unadjusted and adjusted you know types
detected the same three QTL in the same
locations looking at the genome-wide
prediction results the accuracies there
was an increase whether use an a an MA
one or earth or any moving average or
autoregressive covariance function
however the standard deviations were
quite high and so these this increase
was not so sophisticated looking on how
well the covariance matrix fit the data
and they are one in the nature to here
fit the best but they actually fit the
same because they are two reverted to an
AR one because the B parameter was set
to zero during optimization of in this
case log marginal likelihood or this is
what Rommel optimizes or what Rommel is
so I have two more data sets in this
case I do not have genetic data so I'm
just looking at how well they fit well
the covariance matrices fit the data so
again they're both f1 interspecific
crosses the first one has four O's 76
binds per row again only modeling
covariances within rows about 300 vines
were genotype again for powdery mildew
in 2017 the second vineyard had three
rows 61 binds within those about 200
binds second-year vines were phenotype
for height and so these vines were not
never trimmed and so we could in this
case so there was
here that a or two covariance functions
that the best because they had the
greatest log marginal likelihood so
summarize the thousand two Perry mill
the data said do not show a significant
benefit to just for phenotypes or will
be good to have some more vineyard data
where we could look at into this
especially one where the term deviation
isn't so high and that they are process
processes usually fed been your data
better than moving average processes so
just going back to our overview of
grapevine breeding out where this
research
it's an the high-throughput genotyping
using computer vision helps us being
faster phenotypes for f1 families and
this is where we get our markers that we
use for marker-assisted selection and
accounting for spatial effects could
possibly be to more representative
accurate QTL or ratings in the field and
the Bayesian networks for example
occurred suggest what Ian types should
generally breed for if we want I like
to acknowledge Bruce rice or giving me
the independence to conduct the research
that interested me
lancedale Davidson and Michael Gore were
helping me flush out my research and for
being on my committee and everyone else
here for helping me out with my research
I like to thank my funding sources by
decision which was funded by the USDA
nifA grant and the Charles árboles plant
hybridization down them and Michael
Nolan endowment on thank you and I'll
take any questions
[Applause]
Jimmy let me ask one question Constantin
do you think the work that you did on
the Bayesian network analysis do you
think that could have been applied to
many tech studies and qto QTL analyses
and buy this or do you see that
applicable to the most QTL analyses no
because in most cases we only had I feel
most studies only had one phenotype and
I don't think there's a benefit when
there's just a single phenotype I think
the model will be very similar to what
you get with that single phenotype QTL
analysis
did you try using multiple rows instead
of just within row spatial adjustment
accounting for the the six so you said
you had multiple rows yeah
did you try combining the information in
those rows in your spatial analysis yeah
and it actually decreased again it
wasn't significant just because of the
high standard deviation but I think the
issue there is that the we would have to
sorry I guess I didn't mention this is
that the space between between vines
within a row is different than the space
between rows and so we're going to need
different a and B parameters when we fed
between row covariances and since we
only have six vines or sorry because we
only have six loads those parameters are
likely not to be late yes really well
estimated which I feel is what happened
oh yeah so technically Vitis vinifera
has leaf trichomes but they're
practically not seeing a belief this
image actually but those really dense
leaf trichomes they do are never present
and Vitis vinifera the their present and
certain of vitae species like a scenario
and a Brassica just saying today I think
they're it's the most common so it's not
not all while species have these vents
leaf trichomes but just some dude the
interesting thing about the trichomes is
servants most that is just on the
inheritance
trade lines - I think some of them some
of your analyses pointed to the
inheritance patterns of trichomes and
they're also related to the ecological
niche in which certain types of types of
predatory mites insist on great weights
so you actually encourage certain
predatory mites to live on great needs
just by reading code for our trichomes
entities there's a nation images okay
well the GEMA question well
more questions thank you for coming to
my
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu